hi Tyler hi Nikki how are you I'm good
how are you good thank you good
um so what was it like being sort of
back in this role back with like you
know this cast and in particular
reuniting with Crystal
oh yeah it was incredible
um you know the cast and I have done a
really good job at uh maintaining our
friendship and trying to hang out as
much as possible but Crystal you know I
haven't seen her much since since she
left the show and she lives in a
different state now and so it was
incredible you know and and seeing how
we've both grown up in our ideal sort of
align with each other we're both we
meditate in the mornings and um it was
just nice to have a different
connection with her because last time I
saw her 20 it was almost 10 years ago it
was like 23 24 so you know being able to
see her as a 30 year old now for me it
was really cool to see how you know
we've aligned over the last few years
well that leads into my next question
which is you know this show the show you
know premiered over a decade ago what's
the biggest change you've seen in
yourself since then
oh my God
uh yeah I'm just a little bit more
settled you know as an adult I still
like to
think that I'm I'm pretty much the same
you know
um
I uh I just I'm more present I'm more
settled I'm I'm less
um
uh interested in what other people think
about me
um
you know I'm still growing I'm still
figuring things out but uh I'm just I'm
very happy with where I am today and I'm
covered in tattoos and I have a mustache
those are a little bit different love it
um I love the story that you shared
where you would auditioned to play Jacob
in Twilight I just have to ask you is
there like a thing with you and
werewolves I mean what is this yeah
there might be the universe knows what
it wants and
um I was destined to be a werewolf and
you know what look at the success of
Teen Wolf I guess it was It was supposed
to happen you know and people love this
Scott the true Alpha
um and I'm you know I'm happy that I'm
able to play that role for the universe
for the world it just it needed to
happen I don't know it's interesting how
how that worked out you're gonna play a
werewolf one way or another I think
that's right yeah
um you know some of the cast in a return
in particular Dylan was it weird not
having him on set and if there is a
sequel let's say I would do you hope he
would return for that
um I mean of course you know I always
want to work with Dylan and even outside
of Teen Wolf I would love to do another
thing with him I just don't know if it's
possible because the connection of us
and Teen Wolf
um
so Dylan wasn't a part of the last
season of Teen Wolf so it wasn't weird
not having him on set
um but he but at the same time he's
still always there with us you know we
can't really have the evolution in the
history of Teen Wolf without Styles he's
sort of implemented in our our our
Cadence of how we write and how we film
um so he's he's always there with us you
know so even though he wasn't there in
person his element and his Vibe is still
very much there so and his Jeep is
always there
always the Jeep
um you know the the fans I mean they're
still so passionate about this show what
does that mean to you to have their
support over these years
everything it means everything and I
feel like there's not enough that I can
do to show them that I am thankful and I
want to have more intimate moments with
them and I do my best to go to each
Comic-Con and sit and talk with them and
have private moments to let them know
like I am super grateful and we are one
family and I love them I love their
passion I relate to them with it and
it's just I can talk for hours about how
how grateful I am for it and how much I
want to I keep trying to quiz myself on
how I could be doing more for the fans
to let them know that like you're the
reason why this is happening why why why
we're still going on this aside from me
loving the artwork and the show itself
and my character
it's for the fans like who who the hell
else would it be for you know what I
mean like it's it's it they're a bigger
part of the show than I am than we are
there or there is just a much a part of
it so like they need to be commemorated
and they need to be honored and
respected and know that know that they
are such a huge part of it so I really
hope it transcends through me or through
the show and and we show our gratitude
for them so I'm working on it every
single day and try to find a new way to
do it